now the best way to understand the
metaverse is to experience it yourself
[Music]
[Music]
yeah i definitely don't feel very well
right now and you wouldn't feel well
either if you attempted to spend 24
hours living in virtual reality or the
metaverse don't know what the metaverse
is
that's okay i'm not sure anyone really
does but meta formerly known as facebook
microsoft and more are defining it as
the virtual world that is the next phase
of the internet in this world we have
digital versions of ourselves or avatars
and we call this the metaverse
and you're gonna be able to do almost
anything you can imagine get together
with friends and family work learn play
shop
so i decided why wait and stupidly i
dared myself to visit the metaverse for
a full 24 hours in its current not so
great state in fact metta and others
will tell you that the metaverse isn't
even here yet
but the best way to see the start of it
is through virtual reality and since i
didn't want to pop into a headset with
my kids running around i packed my bags
and moved to the holiday inn express
around the corner i set a few rules the
headset can come off to eat and go to
the bathroom no
yes i attempted to sleep with it on i
checked my phone only if it was urgent i
had notifications coming into the oculus
quest 2 headset which is made by meta
it's about to be 6 p.m which is the
start of my metaverse journey i've got
two headsets in case of technical issues
and lots of apps and other things
pre-loaded for different parts of the
day and night
what could go wrong
welcome to beat saber now cut the cubes
in the arrow direction and match the
color that was too soon wait for the
beat wrong direction wrong direction
she's very mean i started with games
like beat saber since right now they're
the most popular use of vr and while
many games allow you to play with others
i had no real friends to play beat saber
with that evening so i decided to go
elsewhere for some social interaction
alt space vr an app that allows you to
hang out with other avatars in virtual
venues
okay i'm going to customize my avatar
for a night out
i guess in the metaverse i could have
short hair
i wasn't exactly prepared for what would
happen next i guess i'll go to this
campfire hub
hello as soon as i was in the public
area i started hearing people talk and
chat and
apparently there are no masks in the
metaverse i was dropped into an area
with lots of trippy little lego looking
people and i attempted to interview them
questions
oh wow i want to learn what you guys do
in here pretty much everything that you
would do in the real world
i knew i had really made friends forever
when they asked me to go to a comedy
club by clicking on this portal thing
the club was so obviously fake but my
presence in it and the presence of all
these other people felt really real do
you guys have wine yeah of course wine
everything you wanna just imagine i even
felt awkward when the comedian hid on my
avatar you're the girl that was trying
to find out your name but because
i'm trying to be subtle i spent a good
amount of time in alt space and came
away thinking it's like an aol chat room
evolved which i'm not sure is a good or
a bad thing
to relax for a moment
a meditation app is launched
kindness starts with you i highly
recommend meditation apps like guided
meditation or trip
it's oddly relaxing and peaceful and i
could lie to you and tell you i slept
with the headset on the whole night but
we have this proof
[Music]
i woke up feeling refreshed i pulled up
some morning reading in my web browser
google news over here
the wall street journal website over
here
and instagram over here on the right and
had breakfast at the foot of machu
picchu with a llama in the national
geographic app it's funny this animal
has legs in the metaverse
white animals get four legs in the
meadowverse and we get zero
and then i had a pretty fun and intense
workout
welcome to supernatural you ready for
your first flow workout there are
various types of workouts you can do in
supernatural which involve everything
from doing lunges to using controllers
to hit targets
i got so into it i actually lost track
of time
i have a meeting in spatial in one
minute i need to change
crap yes meetings in the metaverse are a
thing
hi erin i'm joanna nice to meet you hi
thanks for coming the idea is that
instead of zoom you chat as avatars my
first meeting was in an app called
spatial and of course it required a
different avatar yes that's my actual
face on a floating torso
i met up with the co-founder of spatial
ananda agrawala in an nft art gallery
with works from ken kelleher aka anchor
ball on display this is a great stop
because it turns out i'm in an nft art
gallery which sounds like the metaverse
to me
heck yeah i mean you can't get more
metaversy than a you know pixelated dog
or
uh these crazy heads and stuff or these
beautiful sculptures we also went to a
campfire where i asked him about the
lack of legs right the headset tracks
your head and your hands and so we can
make it do realistic stuff what are my
legs supposed to do we can't actually
detect the signal from your legs legs
are coming coming soon i quickly had to
jump from that meeting to another
meeting as another avatar in horizon
workrooms an app made by metta formerly
known as facebook oh i see so it's kind
of like you gotta really put it on the
board
you can even invite people from the
realverse who happen to be on their
webcams but again there was this real
feeling of presence in the room i felt
like i was actually sitting across from
my editor wilson in this meeting it's
liking ghostbusters i'm a full torso
apparition you don't need legs
oh no jan is looking under the table
that's so scary
yes meeting metaverse is fun if you
don't do it for four hours on end
that was so much time in avatar meetings
my eyes hurt and my head hurts
so what did i learn from this adventure
other than i'd never recommend you do
this well a few things it's clear why
big tech companies are fighting over
this there's an opportunity to build the
underlying platform here one avatar with
legs living across games workout apps
meetings and more
meta's megan fitzgerald told me as much
and the metaverse is not going to be
built by one company that there are
other companies organizations creators
that maybe will use um our avatars and
allow people to move from one place to
another while still feeling like
themselves then there's the privacy
tools and moderation it's gonna be
insane judging from my brief comedy club
experience
and then headsets will need to be
smaller and more comfortable and run for
longer on a charge thank you guys my
headset's gonna die in five minutes so
yes it's certainly the early days of the
metaverse but lock yourself in a room
like this and you can really see the
potential